Susy is living in a safe house having
escaped her captor she was brought to
the UK by a man from Ghana who promised
to marry her but things changed when she
arrived he said he's a man she can't do
whatever you want to do I shouldn't ask
me any questions you know how much he
played to brought me this country she
know how much this and that so I just
shut my mouth the person want to sleep
with you
the first thing don't care about you
they don't care about what you eat they
don't care about anything I just wanna
cry just false false false like you any
mind they don't feel like anything for
you they don't think about you they
don't cry by you the person says he
loved you but they don't cry by you they
don't okay have a break have a break
Susie's distress is understandable the
man who held her took her passport told
her she'd be arrested if she went to the
police
and for years kept her as a sex slave oh
I didn't need selfishness
they cry about yourself the ones who
rule your life they want to sleep with
you that's it they treated like a rock
how long did you live with this AB you
that in so many years I hate them
under government guidelines the Home
Office should decide within 45 days
whether there are conclusive grounds to
categorize Susy as a victim of modern
slavery but she's been waiting much
longer I'm green nearly 1 year 6 months
1 year 6 month and you still haven't got
that recognition yet no sadly a year and
a half wait is not unusual for a
decision that should take days earlier
this year the Prime Minister described
modern slavery as the great human rights
issue of our time on a trip to Africa
she announced measures to tackle the
problem of trafficking but charities say
some victims aren't being properly
supported and some even fall back into
slavery because of difficulties and
delays in reality what we're seeing is
that victims are waiting much much
longer for those decisions so the
average wait time for a conclusive
grounds decision last year was 303 days
but there is a constant background
anxiety of them knowing that any day a
decision could come through the post it
could be a decision in their favor or it
could not be a decision in their favor
and that can really hamper someone's
ability to meaningfully recover in that
time this art exhibition in London
features photos of and artwork by former
slaves here we met the government's
former independent anti-slavery
Commissioner Kevin Hyland before
resigning he recommended processes were
speeded up and protections improved
he says the Home Office agreed to his
proposals but a year on hasn't
implemented any of them we know that
there are problems they've been
identified the solutions have been put
forward and a year later we're still
waiting for those to be implemented I
think we have to accept that's just not
good enough
one of the things I highlighted to the
government was the fact that it was
taking so long to make decisions and in
many ways you know it's not the funding
that's put into this that's the problem
it's the decision-making because if
those decisions were made in a much
shorter time that funding could be used
to give the victims other opportunities
education work and whatever else that
may be a year and a half her decision is
just not right and it's a year and a
half of living in limbo and what is life
like for those people well these people
are in a way on
held on a piece of string in 2014 a home
office study estimated there were
between 10 and 13 thousand slaves in the
UK but the walk free foundation recently
suggested there could be as many as a
hundred and thirty six thousand more
than five thousand victims of slavery
and trafficking were referred to the
police in the last year alone
that's a 35 percent increase on the year
before even if someone is formally
recognised by the Home Office as a
victim of modern slavery
they are only entitled to 14 days
additional specialist support they may
still have to make an asylum claim they
may still struggle to find accommodation
sexual exploitation is the most common
form of slavery Suzy has this message
for any victim who happens to be
watching anybody who come here anything
happens you go to the police report to
the police police will help you to go
away from your situation that is oles
and I'm gonna tell everybody the Home
Office says slavery cases can take time
because of their complexity but new
reforms will markedly improve the
systems for identifying and supporting
victims Jason Farrell Sky News